Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott are
expecting a baby girl now we are
breaking down a timeline of their love
trust me I see many we keep up either
the couple first went public with their
romance at Coachella in April I'm having
so much fun just weeks after Kylie split
from her on-again off-again boyfriend
Tyga later that month the duo flew to
the rapper's hometown of Houston where
they were spotted cozying up courtside
at an NBA game I'm just like really
genuinely happy right now in June they
made their love permanent showing off
matching tiny butterfly tattoos on
snapchat I'm obsessed with her after he
released his song butterfly effect which
many fans speculated was about Kylie
then et learned on Friday that the two
are expecting a baby girl excited about
it and a source tells ety quote Kylie
always wanted to be a young mom despite
the reports the famous family is staying
quiet even to their boss keeping up
executive producer Ryan Seacrest chris
says Kylie's not confirming anything
Kylie's momager also dodged questions
about the news telling The Hollywood
Reporter over the weekend quote it
wouldn't be the family if something
didn't happen every single day there's
always something that that happens now
in a new feature interview with Rolling
Stone they report that the 25 year old
rapper was professing his love for the
20 year olds reality star weeks before
the news of her pregnancy broke this is
cool according to the mag Scott FaceTime
the life of Kylie star backstage at his
show telling her quote I just got off
stage I miss you I love you
[Music]